puisque démoli
ces produits bio mystère
la patrie
konaté
ou alors vous êtes
[Musique]
le jour où la vidéo a été diffusée on a
tout arrêté tout simplement et on s'est
mis uniquement à répondre à toutes les
demandes qui défilait constamment on a
reçu des dizaines et des dizaines de
demandes de boulanger qui étaient
intéressés par le concept et qui avait
envie d'être équipé du kram beurre ce
qu'on a pu faire cours en 2019 a eu un
impact absolument énorme à la fois sur
mon projet mais surtout sur la lutte
contre le gaspillage de pain parce que
chaque boulangerie qui a le crâne leurs
barreaux valorisé en moyenne 2 tonnes de
pain par an ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
si on a une centaine de boulanger qui
sont équipés de la machine on a un
impact chaque année de 200 tonnes de
pain qui sont revalorisés alors là on
est à bordeaux et on va aller rencontrer
un des boulangers qui utilisent la
machine et donc nous voilà devant la
boulangerie pomponnettes allez on y va
comment tu vois ça va super
c'est très simple il ya deux moutons
à marche et une coupure de sécurité donc
souvent fait c'est qu'on tranche d'info
pain on le passe au four grillé et après
on ajoute vous avez un broyeur
réduit donc le vin
chaque jour 1
oui mais d'arriver
certains jours je t'ai de brossac
en véhicules banalisés sachant que les
associations nous reliant bordeaux
le passé
plus se déplacer
ces troubles
donc là maintenant
g je jette quasiment plus de blancs
vous avez une chapelure une première
capture ici qui est faite avec du pain
de la veille
donc il ya ces grossières et surtout qui
est assez humide et surtout tout ce qui
entoure muffins et c'est l'autre côté
sari de la chapelure très fine
on utilise pour le pas qui est faite
avec du budget pas gagné - du coup tu va
nous présenter les petites innovations
qui est à fait avec le crooner allée des
vas-y prix normal que je suis très tenté
par le devine sa meuf in congo promener
seul essai d'eau coulant oui donc ce
film contient 20% de caplan alors la
cellule il va faire plaisir à ses
très cool franchement il est au top et
les clients il est généreux tout ce
qu'on aime dans un muffin et il est anti
gaspi les boulangers vont pouvoir jouer
sur le type de pain qui est broyé sur le
pourcentage qui vont réintégrer dans des
recettes sur la dureté du pain est ce
qu'il est très sec ou est-ce qu'il est
encore mou et donc on n'a pas de
boulangerie au final qui vont avoir
exactement les mêmes recettes
et plus on avance dans la démarche plus
on a deux boulangeries qui sont dans le
réseau des utilisateurs
mais plus on a l'idée dans le pays
basque on va avoir des boulangeries qui
font du gâteau basque
en alsace on a des pâtisseries
alsacienne du coeur en fonction des
régions on a aussi des déclinaisons
locales
on a installé le chrome leur évidemment
en france mais également dans des pays
comme en europe en croatie en suisse en
belgique et un peu plus loin donc on est
installé des machines en guadeloupe en
martinique au sénégal au burkina et
aujourd'hui on a la chance et l'
enthousiasme de force et dire qu'on peut
avoir un impact non seulement à
l'échelle de la france mais également du
monde entier parce que finalement le
problème du gaspillage de pain il n'est
pas présent que chez nous il est présent
absolument dans le monde entier c'est
clair que demain on espère que le crâne
lors va devenir une machine standard
finalement dans le milieu des boulangers
pour pouvoir tout naturellement
revaloriser les invendus et que ça ne
viennent même plus à l'idée d'une
boulangerie de jeter du pain en fin de
journée
[Musique]